hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar titled
antibody therapy against sars
kobe 2 a global collaboration this
webinar is part of the coronavirus
virtual event series
i am sabrina lemmons of lab roots and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinth
now let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions
as you would like during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the ask the
question box located on the far
left of your screen as a reminder this
presentation
is educational and offers free education
excuse me continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab
located in the top right corner of the
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speaker erica
ullman sapphire
phd professor at la jolla institute for
immunology
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr allman sapphire you may now begin
your presentation
thank you um i'm pleased to join you
today so i'm joining you
on behalf of this international
consortium kovic the chronovirus
immunotherapeutics consortium it was
launched in march from the covid19
therapeutics accelerator
supported by the gates foundation
mastercard welcome trust and others
and studies were subsequently expanded
this summer by
nih and the ghr foundation
so all of us around the world are
praying for immunity in the form of
vaccines to get back to any
sense of normalcy and get back to work
get back to school and get back to
seeing our relatives
and while we wait for those to come out
we are cognizant that there will be
some complications the vaccines will not
be
in all places at all times there will be
people who will
are not vaccinated not vaccinated yet
right now that's all of us who there are
people who
can't be vaccinated and in whom
vaccines don't take or just didn't last
what if immunity only lasts a year and
coronavirus comes back
in another year and so
there's another way in which we can
help rescue some of those people in whom
vaccines didn't take or didn't last or
who haven't yet been vaccinated
and that is antibody therapy so a major
goal
of a vaccine is to produce antibody
ideally neutralizing antibody
in the recipients and vaccines would
also induce innate immune responses and
t
cells i'm going to talk to you about the
antibody response
the hope is that by presenting
a viral protein a viral antigen the
spike protein
usually in the chronovirus vaccines your
immune system would be primed and have
an antibody response at the ready
then after several weeks after exposure
you have this antibody response on deck
so that you can attack and clear any
entering virus and prevent
disease now the vaccines
have a variable response some
have some people will have a stronger
antibiotic response other people
have a weaker antibody response in
initial data
often it takes a shot in a booster and
it might be
five weeks for the anti to arrive and
this is what we need in order to achieve
population protection but there's
another way
in which you can get antibody right away
and deliver it as a drug and this is
important for people who have become
infected
and are not yet vaccinated or in whom a
vaccine didn't take or in a
preventing infection as someone like a
frontline medical worker
and that's delivering the right kind of
antibody right away as a drug we call
that antibody therapy or immunotherapy
and we have a lot of history with
delivering antibodies directly usually
by iv
for diseases we have very potent
antibodies against
cancers that can seek out and help
destroy individual cancer cells
we have antibodies against infectious
diseases we have antibodies that help
dampen autoimmune diseases and of course
we're all familiar with anti-venom
anti-venom is polyclonal antibody
against the snake toxin and you know
with anti-venom
as with antiviral antibody earlier is
better than later
for antivenom you want that shot of that
polyclonal antitoxin antibody right away
to save your leg and save your life
after a snake bite same thing with
antiviral antibody in the first
earlier stage of infection it's better
when you can knock down the amount of
circulating virus
so an antibody is a natural human a
molecule
it is what you would want and expect
your own immune system to make have been
given the opportunity
but by finding them making them in gmp
facilities
and delivering them by iv you can give
somebody the antibody
they wish they had right away it is
a transient form of protection it might
last three weeks you can engineer them
to last about six months
and so it won't last forever but it will
get you through a crisis
and it's important that for some people
with certain underlying conditions it
doesn't induce
any lasting change in the immune system
it doesn't require
a fully functioning immune system it
just gives you the antibody you wish you
had right away
and it can be used to prevent infection
or to treat people who have already
become infected
now the antibodies that we have to work
with to
discover the ones that might be used as
therapies are those that have been made
from people made in people that have
already survived infection
so usually the very first survivors
early in the pandemic
donated their blood and in their blood
cells researchers searched for
antibody molecules that would be the
most effective
there's a lot of possibilities there are
a quintillion
possible antibodies in human serum so
that's a quintillion it's one with 18
zeros behind it
and that's a lot of possible antibodies
from all the sequence
arrays and within any one survivor there
will be a range of antibodies present
against
perhaps whatever they have been infected
with
or vaccinated against a
a percent or a fraction percent would be
against
sars-kopi-2 the infection we want to
find an antibody against
and so within that giant haystack you
want to find the very best
individual antibodies against stars cov2
the needles in the haystack
and how do you find them well you have
to look into the array of what's
available so an antibody is shaped like
a y
it's got two arms it's got a base at the
end of the arms
is a combinatorial binding site there
are hypervariable loops that make the
structure of that end
different from any antibody from every
antibody so that's
your antibody these would be foreign
invaders like the virus that fit
with a very special shape and charge
complementarity
into that end of the antibody that we
call the fragment antigen binding
and that end is so precise it operates
as
sort of like fingerprint recognition so
a particular antibody would recognize a
certain site on a certain pathogen and
only that they're very precise it's
laser targeted for a particular pathogen
so this is what they really look like
this is a
structure from my lab of the surface
spike protein of a virus on the left
and then the y-shaped human antibody on
the right
and you can get a sense of the scale how
the antibody fits a particular shape an
articular part of that
pathogen
so there are millions of possible
antibodies and we want to find the very
best
one or two that we might deliver as a
drug
so you probably heard about convalescent
serum being delivered to survivors
that's just
the whole array of different antibodies
right from one survivor
into the veins of another and that
convalescent serum is quite variable
because it comes straight from a person
so it'll contain antibodies against
whatever they've been infected with or
vaccinated with before
and some have very potent responses
against the virus of interest and some
have weak
the goal of a monoclonal antibody
therapy is just to find the very best
one or two antibodies among the millions
that are made
scale those up and just deliver those
just deliver the needles from the
haystack
so the question is if you're searching
among those millions of antibodies how
do you find the very best one or two
that are the best
another question is how do you define
best
what makes the best how do you determine
in the lab
what's going to work best in a human
what experiment would you do or what
feature of the antibody which you look
for
that's going to forecast protective
function
the other thing is that often we don't
just deliver one antibody called the
monotherapy we deliver
a mixture it's called a cocktail two
seems to be the magic number that
we often use sometimes three if you're
gonna find two antibodies
delivered together you know one
advantage would be that they hit two
different footprints
and so it's harder for the virus to
mutate to escape two things at once and
one thing at once
and if you're delivering two things at
once you might as well find two things
that are complementary to each other
sometimes you can find antibodies that
synergize where the hole is greater than
the sum of the parts maybe a binding of
one
opens up the binding side of the other
so the pair together is better than you
might expect
either one alone to be and if you're
going to make the
a cocktail of antibodies you're going to
find a pair what's the best pair
how do you know how do we search among
all the different antibody therapies
being mobilized for and decide what's
the best
right now there are at least 75
different efforts
around the world trying to discover
and mobilize these antibodies is pre or
post-exposure therapy
which ones are the best and how do we
know well another variable
is that the assays or the experiments
you might do
to try to evaluate antibodies can give
different results in different
labs even if it looks like the same
protocol the viruses they use could be a
different passage number they could be
using them in a different cell line the
cells could be a different passage
number they could the resulting
cells could differ in receptor
populations on the surface or the viral
viruses being produced could different
glycosylation state
so and you know a certain value of the
ability the antibody to neutralize from
one lab might be different from that
evaluated in another lab
and so if you are choosing antibody
therapies to go
forward into clinical trials and humans
how do you look
among the playing field and try to find
the ones
that have the best chances of success
how do you compare
different groups competing efforts
well first we might talk about how we
might use these antibodies
because how you might use them
determines how you might
evaluate them so you would use an
antibody therapy
in an attempt to save lives here from an
infectious disease and you can use them
for treatment or you can use them for
prevention
for treatment the best use is going to
be in finding
people in early stage disease people
with mild to moderate covet 19 who are
at risk of developing severe disease say
elderly people people with underlying
immune complications
if you can treat them with antibody
early in the stage of infection
you can knock down the quantity of virus
you can reduce their viral load
prove outcomes of disease lilly's first
trial results came out this week and it
looks like treatment with monoclonal
antibody reduced hospitalization rates
of people that had received the
treatment
so that's good it could prevent someone
from progressing to severe disease and
save lives
another use of the antibodies in
prevention so people on the front lines
health care workers first responders
high risk groups like pregnant women
or to mop up a disease outbreak let's
say there was
a number of cases in a high risk
facility like a nursing home
you could treat the other residents and
the staff with antibody to prevent
them from being infected and that's
important when vaccines haven't yet been
mobilized
or in people in whom vaccines are less
likely to take
like the elderly and the
immunocompromised so we would use the
antibodies in
two different situations the goal of the
of the consortium kovic that i'm going
to tell you about was to evaluate all of
the different candidate antibody
therapies being mobilized forward to
figure out
which among them are best what makes
them best and what assays best get us
there
and our funding comes from different
sources it gives us different mandates
so our primary goals of this consortium
to figure out what the best antibody is
and why
is a translational research goal we're
evaluating all the molecules going
forward for
therapeutic efforts side by side under
standardized assays comparing them
to each other in annapolis apple's way
in the same experimental conditions to
figure out
which one of them are more potent and
what kinds of features they have how are
they differ from each other do they hit
different footprints so if the virus
goes and mutates
which ones are still applicable our
other mandate and this is especially
from the bill and melinda gates
foundation
is to find those antibodies that we can
mobilize to low and middle income
countries and so we're looking for those
that are
very highly potent if an antibody is
very potent you don't need as many
milligrams to do the job if you don't
need as many
many as many milligrams to do the job
what you can manufacture can go to more
people we're also looking for those
antibodies of
great stability so that cold chain is
less of an issue an easy
manufacturability you know you might
have a molecule that looks absolutely
fantastic in the lab but if you can't
make it at a useful scale to treat
people
it's no help to you and so while we are
comparing
all of the therapeutic candidates
rushing forward to clinic
we're looking for those we can use to
save lives in low and middle income
countries as well
so our primary goals were translational
but with my academic hat on
while we have compiled the study put
together this study while we have
70 you know over 75 different partners
aligned to figure out what the right
antibodies are
and all of their antibodies together in
one place we can have the opportunity to
really learn something
we can look at the whole array of
different candidates being discovered
evaluated and chosen by different groups
and figure
out the landscape of different ways in
which antibodies can protect against the
virus
if we have this larger data set of
everybody's antibodies from all the
different discovery engines
we can make a broader deeper data set to
understand
what features of an antibody make one
more protective than another
let's say we could have it do we find
that at a certain site they elicit
natural killer cell functions at
another site you can achieve the most
potent neutralization
and then the other goal while we have
all the different antibodies of the
consortium and all the different
experimental labs of the consortium
and simultaneous human clinical data
coming back
we have a chance to figure out which in
vitro
experiments best forecast within vivo
success
and that's a really unique opportunity
for chronovirus so for most infectious
diseases
you discover something in the lab you
evaluate it in your plastic tissue
culture dishes and the things that you
think are best based on whatever you're
doing in vitro
you might try in rodents and if they
look work in rodents you might try them
in primates if they work in primates
then you proceed toward human testing
well we have an opportunity now where
the human testing is
in the same year as our in vitro and
early and vivo experiments it's not 10
years later so there's an opportunity
for immediate feedback
and information on our discovery
pipeline
do our in-vivo pre-clinical models
really forecast
in vivo success how about the in vitro
models which are the features that are
actually correlating with what works in
humans so we have a chance here
to not only evaluate the candidates but
evaluate our whole research pipeline
so the goal of the consortium is to put
everyone's antibodies and everyone's
expertise
in the same place to move forward faster
and more completely with a better
informed study
why would you go to this effort of a
very large-scale international
consortium
instead of looking at antibodies within
just one wheelhouse
and the answer is that we think we can
get
broader deeper information each
individual
discovery engine has their own set of
assays and their own criteria
we might get different kinds of
information by comparing different
efforts
so an example of what we might learn by
doing a broader study
than just analyzing the antibodies from
one group alone
comes from the work that we did for
ebola virus at the outset
of the major west african outbreak in
2014
right before that outbreak in 2013
actually the ebola virus field had this
set of results
we had an antibody a neutralizing
antibiotic i'm showing that to you in
orange that's just the fab fragment one
arm of the y
they neutralized beautifully of cell
culture and it could inactivate the
virus that's what we thought
that an antibody should be able to do
but it couldn't protect non-human
primate models
and at the same time there was a
cocktail of three antibodies and i'm
showing you there
fab fragments in purple and blue some of
them recognize a disordered heavily
glycosylated domain that we know is at
the top but we don't know exactly the
structure
this cocktail of three didn't neutralize
virus and cell culture
but it did protect the non-human primate
models
and so we have one antibody that
neutralizes and didn't protect in a
cocktail that protected in the absence
of neutralization
now we had thought that whether or not
that antibody could inactivate virus and
cell culture was the primary
thing that we would want an antibody to
do and then sorting antibodies by
neutralization would help forecast what
was going to give us in vivo's success
but it wasn't so there was something
different going on
is it that it the blue pair
blue purple set was protective because
it was a cocktail
maybe we just need to hit multiple sites
at once or maybe it had something to do
with a domain we call the fc
that's the base of the y that's the part
that recruits immune cell
function you can see and under the
details under the mb03 cocktail and if
you produced it in one cell type
cho you didn't get as effective
protection as if you produce it in a
different cell type in nicotiana and the
difference is the glycan put on the fc
and how well it binds to fc receptors to
recruit immune cell health
so maybe there was something we needed
to understand about the ability of this
antibodies to recruit immune cell health
the other possibility was that
neutralization just wasn't
enough maybe there was something else
that the orange guy was missing
or maybe we weren't measuring
neutralization properly maybe the
way we in the field had been evaluating
antibody neutralization wasn't
taking into account the right metrics or
the right features or the right values
to forecast in success
another possibility is that the ebola
virus field had just looked at too small
a number of antibodies at the time
we had found the exceptions rather than
the rule
but we knew that we as a research field
needed to figure this out quickly
and so we formed a consortium the viral
immunotherapeutic consortium
vic which gathered the molecules of 43
labs across
five continents whether they were
academic laws or industry labs or
government labs and we started with 168
monoclonals we eventually went up to
setting 230
and we measured 32 different features of
the antibodies side by side
to figure out what are the different
things that an antibody could do and
which of them were
more strongly linked to in vivo success
what were the best antibodies and why
and what experiment would we do to find
them
and so as part of this we wondered if we
were measuring neutralization the right
way
there's lots of different ways we could
measure whether an antibody would
neutralize and cell culture
so we looked we compared different
ways of measuring neutralization of
ebola virus and culture one was
actual ebola virus one was a bsl3 model
another one was a common pseudovirus
system and they differed
in the presence and absence of a
secreted dimeric version and how
the readout was and so we took our 230
antibodies and we separated them by
their epitope
where on the viral surface protein they
found in these different categories cap
head and use and base
and then we evaluated every single one
of these antibodies their ability to
neutralize in four different ways
those three different systems and also
the percentage of viruses that are left
unneutralized the bit the antibody
leaves behind
and we plotted each one of these
antibodies so you see in the blue box
those are antibodies against the glycan
cap and there's antibody number one and
antibiotic number three and anybody
number five all they have to add by 156.
we can plot their ability to neutralize
in each one of these assays whether it
was strong and blue
moderate and orange or weak or not at
all in red
and if you zoom in for example into the
cap domain you find
antibodies like these that are
sort of what we expect they don't
neutralize in any assay
all four boxes are red and they
don't protect an animal model or the
projection is kind of weak that's what
we're expecting they don't neutralize
they don't protect
we have found other antibodies like
antibody five and antibody a
that did neutralize or neutralize most
of the time
but still didn't protect the animal
model and then there are other
antibodies like these
that only neutralized the authentic
ebola virus ebov
didn't neutralize in other systems and
some of them were highly protected
so that's interesting there's something
that the measurement of the authentic
virus neutralization picks up that the
other methods did not
and if you look across the whole data
set of different antibodies against
different sites and whether
they neutralize in culture versus
protect in vevo we get
these results there are those that do
what we thought antibodies ought to do
they neutralize in cell culture they
protect in animal models and they
protect because they neutralize and some
of these robustly neutralize no matter
how you measure it
there are other antibodies that do
things we weren't expecting
here are some that neutralize and
sometimes they neutralize really
potently
but they don't protect an animal model
they're missing something
and here are antibodies that protect in
the absence of any measurable
neutralization at all in any system
so whatever it is they're doing we're
not measuring it in that cell culture
model
and here's a set of antibodies that are
protective and they mostly don't
neutralize
they only neutralize authentic ebola
virus and sometimes they're kind of
crummy at that
so they're doing something else and
the authentic ebola virus is picking up
from that model so if we look at the
outliers
we can see what we can learn and this is
why it was helpful to do that large 43
lab 230 antibody study
that sometimes the lab would have one
outlier and they just have one antibody
that's weird that you tried to ignore it
but when you find 15 that all have
something in common
then you have a body to study and so
that's what we gained by doing this
broad
trans lab study if you look at the
outliers which is those that neutralize
and fail to protect in animals or those
that protect but
in the absence of measurable
neutralization you see what's different
the ones that protect without
neutralizing to protect by doing
something that doesn't block
mechanical blocking a viral entry they
tend to inspire those effective
protection mechanisms by the base of the
fc so they inspire phagocytosis
or natural killer cell functions they
inspire the immune system to come and
destroy
infected cells and by destroying
infected cells those infected cells are
no longer factories to make more virus
so it's that immune mediated protection
that let these guys be protected
and the ones that neutralized meaning
they could block with separate binding
or block
rearrangements of the glycoprotein
required to enter cells they could
mechanically inactivate the virus
but they still weren't protective what
are they missing the answer is they're
weaker at inspiring phagocytosis or
natural killer selectivity
so that told us we needed two kinds of
things we needed neutralization
functions and we needed
fc effector functions and in fact we did
we had so much data from 230 antibodies
and measuring
lots of different features about them
that we could rank order those features
and you could make a logistic regression
model
of of all the different things we did
your things you could measure
high throughput and in vitro which of
them correlate with protection
in the in vivo model so blue bar is a
good thing that's a protective feature
red bar is a bad thing that's a feature
that links to
not protection big bar
is important a strong correlator tiny
bar that doesn't get off
zero origin isn't very important or
isn't a strong
effector so what do we find we find that
neutralization
is as we had expected an important
predictor
of protection and that the most
effective way of measuring
neutralization is with authentic ebola
virus
it would be a natural amount of the
secreted dimer present
the next most effective thing which we
measured in the vsv system at bsl2
was the fraction left behind the number
of viruses that the antibody couldn't
access
if that antibody left some of those
viruses on the table and couldn't wipe
them out
that was a bad thing that tended to lead
to death
so an antibody that tends to leave a
couple of you know a few percent of
viruses unneutralized they tend to
hit sites that are variable and that
site might vary
vary by the presence or absence of a
carbohydrate but in some molecules it's
there and some molecules it's not and so
the antibody could bind sometimes
that means there's always some virus
that escapes that antibody or the
epitope might
change in conformation or structure so
sometimes the antibody was bound
sometimes the antibody was unbound so
those variable epitopes
did not lead to effective protection so
neutralization was good
but it depended on how you measured it
where the antibody bound and how tightly
turned out to be not as predictive as we
had thought but there are lots of
features about the sc
they did correlate with protection the
kinds of cellular functions that
inspired and the kind of glycans
attached
and then these internal ones were
usually earlier late antibodies first
generation second generation measured
and so what we learned is that
neutralization is indeed an important
predictor of protection
and we should also think about what the
fc is doing as a primary criteria
not just let the fc ride along whereas
exactly where it bound
wasn't as important as what it did when
it got there
and so we learned that we really wanted
two different
kinds of protection brought about by
antibodies we wanted
mechanical neutralization we wanted the
binding of that fab
fragment to inactivate the viral
glycoprotein in some way
and the antibodies that neutralize
tended to bind within that black outline
epitopes like the yellow stalk the red
base the purple fusion loop
things that are existed on the receptor
binding core of the glycoprotein
we also wanted in our antibodies the
ability to inspire sc mediated
protection and that tended to happen
to epitopes on the upper and outer part
of the glycoprotein
that might just be geometric access in
the immune cell the binding of the
antibody
and so we think that we
want to make an antibody cocktail or
find single antibodies that could bring
about both of these functions
and in fact the human clinical data
bears this out of the different
antibodies
monotherapies are cocktails mobilized
and tested in humans in the ebola
outbreak
they either they they frequently pair a
neutralizing molecule
with antibodies that can bring about sc
mediated protection or the one in the
center is a monotherapy that hits a
sweet spot where they both happen
so this is the study that we were
running for ebola virus when we were
asked to set up
a similar analysis for coronavirus this
spring
it was launched by the cova-19
therapeutics accelerator the goal again
to evaluate all the therapeutics heading
to human clinical trials side by side
help distinguish among them and to make
sure that we can find molecules to save
lives in low and middle income countries
now an important part of the code
consortium
as we set up for the ebola consortium is
blinding all the samples
and that is to make the study very fair
so the molecules come in
under their real name and they're all
given a code name
copic 1 copic 45 copic 88
and they by giving them a code name
nobody knows whose molecules are whose
and all analysis and decisions are just
purely
data driven all the samples come in
they're all
quality controlled and anonymized and
then identical boxes
of the antibodies are all shipped out to
partner labs so whatever it is so that
you know different labs are experts in
different things
some sequence glycans others measure
neutralization others mention
better measure those fc functions
every lab participating in this
multi-disciplinary study
takes a piece of the analysis in which
they are experts and they get the box
set of the
you know the identical antibodies all
numbered one to two hundred
so they don't know what they are they're
just getting the data and we put the
data back together
by blinding the samples we can also
protect the investment and the
intellectual property of the companies
so some of the antibodies come from
academics others from non-profits some
from small biotech some from
multinational corporations
they have invested significantly in
discovering and mobilizing and testing
these molecules and a lot of them
have you know valuable intellectual
property investment
and they wouldn't be able to participate
if it wasn't protected in some way and
so the blinding of the study
protects that investment all of the
companies know which antibodies are
theirs
i the pi i don't know their dissembles
one to two hundred to me
but the companies get back all of that
data so there's a benefit to that
there may be different kinds of
experiments they didn't have or
different
arrays of information they weren't able
to get on their own or
they just might be able to find out
where their antibodies land in the pack
they get all that data back and they can
use that for their own
purposes and their own investigational
new drug filings there's the benefit to
different different companies
so the samples come in they're blinded
they're alloquetted distributed to all
the different
experts in the field that are each
analyzing a different component or
feature of the antibody studies
all of that data then comes into a
database called copicdb
and the database is publicly accessible
because all the samples are anonymized
we can build a database that'll be
available to all the researchers around
the world
to look at this landscape of 200
antibodies against cyrus code
2 find out where do they bind what do
they do when they get there
do certain features link to certain
sites
which things link to protection how do
we compare the predictive value of the
different assays that are being done
so that database is going to be an
important and lasting
feature of this consortium and from the
therapeutic candidates we're analyzing
we're going to look and see
which are some novel combinations that
play well together or molecules of
exceptional potency stability and
manufacturability to make sure we can
save lives anywhere in the world
regardless of the ability of the patient
to pay for them
the different sample analysis that we're
doing includes
measuring of binding constants to
different forms and domains and regions
of the spike we're doing high resolution
epitope binning to put the antibodies
into different categories
high resolution structural biology to
measure footprints and contact sites
measuring the activity of the fc in
different ways and whether there's
enhancement or protection
the ability of the antibodies to
neutralize in different viral systems
and cell types
the frequency location and likelihood of
an antibody antibody cocktail the
escapes by mutation
whether or not they confer protection
and animal models
and what novel combinations we might be
able to make or optimize that don't yet
exist
so the samples come in aliquot
distributed blinded
sent out to all these different partners
to each perform a piece of the analysis
the data goes into the kovic db
the antibody owners can view their own
unblinded samples and then the blinded
data from everybody else
and the data is available so here they
ask these are doing so my lab does
structural biology
we do cryo-electron microscopy and x-ray
crystallography to map
structures of the different antibody
epidemics georgia tomorrows and dan
bettinger at cartera and georgia's at
the duke human vaccine institute are
looking at binding studies
how well they find constants doing
epitope bidding
nexulus is performing pseudovirus
neutralization
and alex the crayo's lab at utmb is
point
is performing authentic virus
neutralization the bsl3
khalid alter's lab at the reagan
institute is looking using high
throughput system serology to profile
fc driven activities of all the
different anonymized antibodies
and alex becrea's lab is also looking at
fc function and the resistance of these
antibodies to
any form of antibody mediated
enhancement
texas biomed will look at the ability of
these antibodies to confer protection
pre or post exposure
different animal models and we're also
going to evaluate a novel animal model
that is a mouse not only transgenic for
human ace 2 but also
the neonatal fc receptor to try to see
if this model can
correlate with the half-life of these
antibodies in humans how long they last
that's important for prophylactic
utility ishikawoka's lab will look at
the location and propensity of these
different antibodies to be escaped by
viral mutation
and working with him also is betty
lab of los alamos national labs who's
keeping an eye on mutations that arise
in the coronavirus as it transmits in
human to human
propagation around the world to see if
there are mutations that are rising so
we can see if the candidate therapeutics
will remain
responsive and that's going to be
important as we go through
years or seasons of coronavirus
infection and reinfection
and then byrne peters at la jolla
institute is going to gather and analyze
all this data and is building the
kovicdb database
so i and all the reference labs doing
these experiments
are blinded to the real antibodies name
and source it's just sample 45 to us
operation warp speed and the program
officers and our program manager are
unblinded and so if
the contributor has a chance to call and
say that data is or isn't what we're
expecting or we'd like something rerun
or can you tell us more
and the program officers can use the
quality control
data to make their therapeutic choices
the owners of invites of course know
which ones are theirs they can see the
data as it's collected and they can have
it for their own purposes and they
retain
all their intellectual property they can
keep publishing and developing your
animations as much as they wish
we very much want to see these
therapeutics made available and we want
to see them made available
three months ago so we are trying to
accelerate their
discovery and mobilization efforts and
so
it's you know it was it started as an
idn theory could
could we gather all the different
therapeutic candidates and evaluate them
side by side and really try to learn
some lasting information to make sure
that we can find therapeutic
combinations we can mobilize anywhere in
the world
but would people contribute the answer
is yes they do this is a 96 well
plate of antibodies being shipped off to
one of our partners
we want to thank them very much because
it's it's a tremendous willingness on
the part of these scientists to step up
and help solve a global health crisis
and to
share their therapeutic candidates in
which they've made tremendous investment
for other people
to go and evaluate and the contributors
thus far include
academics nonprofits small biotechs
large biotechs and
major multinational corporations with
antibodies coming from four different
continents around the world
so what's our data so far well it's just
starting to roll in this week
so one question you might ask is we know
that
results vary by lab what neutralizes in
one site might not neutralize another
so does the data of the consortium agree
with that from the antibody contributors
and so this
is some neutralization results from the
covic consortium
on we're looking at a pseudovirus assay
in the vsb background at nexulus
compared to results of a different
pseudovirus
on an hiv backbone reported by the
antibody owner in neutralization of
authentic viruses reported by the
antibody owner
and we get results that are fairly
similar
so they're all single digit nano
gram per ml other times
some antibodies match the neutralization
of the authentic virus
but not pseudovirus results published by
the individual lab
and so i think that different
pseudovirus backgrounds
grow to different titers and have
different glycans and so there may be
differences among assays but what we are
measuring
seems to correlate with our authentic
virus data
and for some other antibodies
particularly those that neutralize only
moderately
we're getting ballpark agreement so for
example we
got an ic50 on our vsc background of six
micrograms per ml
that's a little bit better than the
antibody owner who reported 15
and reported that it did neutralize
authentic virus but we don't know the
specific value
when we look at our binding studies we
see a range of binding either to
jason mcclellan's stabilized hexapro
spike antigen with and without a d614g
mutation that's become fixed
in the world and affinity to just the
receptor binding domain and affinity to
the n-terminal domain so we do have
antibodies against the internal domain
the different molecules tend to bind
better to the trimeric spikes and
individual receptor binding domain
constructs but we have a range of
affinity we have high infinity
antibodies we have lower infinity
antibodies
and the affinity does tend to track a
bit
with neutralization so if we separate
this pile of neutralizing antibodies by
their potency and neutralization says
the ic50 so they're more potent or at
the left
the less potent her at the right by
their affinity
tight binders are at the bottom and
weaker binders are toward the top
and we can separate the antibodies by
those against their separate binding
domain
in the dot a couple against the n
terminal domain and the x
if you look we don't have a large sample
of internal domain antibodies but if you
look at the receptor binding domain
antibodies
on the bottom left those of greatest
affinity
tend to be of greatest potency and that
makes a lot of sense
so if they bind very tightly to the
receptor binding domain they're probably
adequately blocking the ability of the
virus to attach to receptor that
correlates with their potent
neutralization
so we have two n-terminal domain binders
there
these are the most potent against the
receptor binding domain
when we line up the first 93 antibodies
analyzed so far
by their fc effector functions you can
see there's quite a range there are some
that have been
made to be or are naturally super
functional
in phagocytosis in the top or
other functions on the bottom and there
are others that are made to be
effector-less to make sure they couldn't
possibly elicit antibody dependent
enhancement
or other functions and so they correlate
in different ways
this is a way of looking at a pie chart
representation of the different fc
mediated functions of each one of the
antibodies and there's some that have
the with the big colorful pie pieces
that elicit an array
of fc mediated functions and strongly
and there are others
the empty gray circles or the tiny pi
pieces that are made to be effectorless
so we'll see how those perform
differently as different populations
we can cluster them based on their
ability to bind to different sc
receptors mediate functions there
so that's just the first bit of data
that's come in this week and all of our
experiments in progress we're still
contracting for more antibodies
and there's going to be more data to
come this is the setup and the launch
and i'd very much like to thank all of
our experimental partners for doing all
this heavy lifting and analyzing all
these antibodies in great detail
so georgia tomorrow's betty corber sujan
shresta byron peters dan bettinger
yoshikawoka alex bakrev galit alter
three at texas biomedical
luis martinez jordi torreira's and
joanne turner and most of all i'd like
to thank my program manager sharon
chendell ahoy instead of immunology for
the incredible effort of all the quality
control all the concentrations all the
shipping all the coordination
and the communication because i'm blind
in the study
we very much welcome feedback
participation we're still enrolling new
antibodies
and you can find me at the email address
at the bottom and i'm happy to answer
any questions
wonderful thank you so much dr olman so
far
for your pres informative sorry excuse
me thank you for your informative
presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question that you
would like to ask
please do so now you're just going to
click on the ask a question box located
on the far
left of your screen so i have a few
coming in let's get started
our first question um what's your
opinion on using
an excuse my pronunciation um
intervening
intravenous in immunoglobulin
intravenous thank you immunoglobulin in
covid patients and in what stage should
it be used
so uh there are two kinds of intravenous
immunoglobulin
probably the question asker means
convalescent sera
and that's the polyclonal whole range of
antibodies from a survivor some of which
are against stars kobe 2 and others are
against whatever else that their immune
system has experienced
and the data are still out and exactly
how effective it is and i think that is
because of the variability some people
have a very strong antibody response
others have a very weak antibody
response so
if you've gotten stronger antibodies you
could expect to get better protection
than if you've gotten weaker
antibodies a more potent and
maybe reliable mechanism of protection
would be the monoclonal antibody
treatments
like the ones that i've described here
and that's not just taking whole
polyclonal all the different antibodies
straight from blood but picking out the
one or two that are very best and just
delivering those so it's like a
laser-guided missile instead of a
barrage of bbs
and the based on the potency of what we
are seeing
go forward we were expecting success and
the first results
presented actually do look successful
that they're able to prevent
hospitalizations that might have
occurred so with antiviral antibody
earlier is better you want to use
antibodies that will
target and inactivate viruses early in
infection
before they grow into too many viruses
and too many infected cells
you would use an antiviral antibody
earlier
later disease the acute respiratory
distress
much of that pathology is an overactive
immune response so at that point
there's not as much virus around so an
antivirus antibody isn't going to be as
helpful
as in something else that would treat
that that
that overactive inflammatory response
and
so a good example would be like
anti-venom you want that anti-venom
right away
you don't want to wait a week or two and
see what happens with the bite
so i would say as soon as you know
that you have been infected you have
this positive test
or if you are a
have a known exposure and you're a
highly vulnerable person
that's when you want to get the antibody
treatment and there are lots of clinical
trials written in lots of different
sites now you can go to
clinicaltrials.gov and look at the
monoclonal antibody trials
and they look for ones and what they're
looking for
some of them want to treat in patients
some of them are specially designed to
treat outpatients and so if you are
feeling just a little sick or not
sick yet but you know you've been
infected that's a really good time to
get that antibody to make sure that you
don't get worse
get it earlier don't wait and see what
happens
thank you and then on the next one i
think correlates
with that one from the same person what
is your opinion about using kobid19
hyperimmune serum
obtained from animals or humans and
which is better
so hyperimmune system hyper immune serum
is another kind of therapy where you
could immunize
an animal over and over again and then
they would develop
very high affinity antibodies and those
can be
more potent than something from a
survivor
who's been infected once the original
forms
were animal antibodies and animal serum
and so you wouldn't
you would want to use them with some
caution so that you don't get serum
sickness or an immune response against
that animal serum
now there are new technologies like
there are cows
that are transgenic for human antibody
genes and immunizing these cows
gives you human antibody and so you
would not
have an immune response against those
and some of those have been evaluated
against the related inverse for example
and so those are great therapies
therapeutic options as well and you
might get those
discovered or available perhaps earlier
than some of the monoclonals
i do like the precision of the
monoclonals it's a very well
characterized response there's often
high resolution structural biology and
very thorough characterization
in vitro and vivo of how these different
antibodies behave
great and does in vitro enhancement
function of antibodies correlate
with in vitro disease enhancement
right so antibodies can neutralize
meaning they block infection
or sometimes they can enhance and if
they enhance infection that means
they're making the infection worse the
antibody has somehow facilitated uptake
of the virus
that is more rare um it is
well characterized for different classes
of viruses like
dengue or zika less so for viruses
shaped like cyrus cov2
typically any neutralizing antibody
if you dilute it enough in a test tube
and take it below the concentration at
which it could possibly neutralize
you can make it look like it enhances in
a test tube or a rodent model
that sometimes but rarely
can correlate with any enhancement of
disease in the animal model
viruses like and i think that
enhancement of disease is something that
everyone was is quite worried about and
looking out for but
it hasn't been observed yet
in the clinical studies for this virus
where it has been observed is something
like dengue so there's four different
kinds of dengue virus
and you make if you get infected with
type 1 you make antibiotics against type
1 and then if
next year you get infected with type 2
your antibodies against type 1
don't bind the different type well
enough to neutralize it instead they
might enhance it and so you get dengue
hemorrhagic fever
a worse outcome of dengue on your second
infection with those
enhancing antibodies that has been less
observed for other diseases
vaccine enhancement was noted for very
early respiratory sensational virus
vaccines when
inactivation of the vaccine particles
sprung
all the surface proteins into the wrong
shape so they made the wrong kind of
antibody
we have sophisticated structural biology
tools now that actually see
what the shape is and can confirm that
it's in the right position so that kind
of misstep isn't going to happen again
so typically enhancement occurs at a
sub-neutralizing concentration
and i although it is something that
everyone is very much
watching for it has not seemed to have
happened
in convalescent sera or monoclonal
antibody administration
starts code 2.
thank you so much um i have an answer a
question coming in about that
question that you just answered are in
vitro enhancing antibodies disqualified
for coping treatment
i would think they would be i think
people look at the
you know if a discovery engine makes a
thousand antibodies
they pick the two most potent and
they're so potent that they just don't
enhance all they do is neutralize and
then
some antibody manufacturers have taken
the tactic
that we want a functioning fc that's the
immune recruiting arm to
mediate that immune cell help others
have taken the tactic that they want to
eliminate
any possibility of enhancement and so
they've made that fc
effector-less they've made that fc
unable to mine to the any
molecules that could facilitate that
uptake
but these molecules that are being
evaluated for human therapy are so
potent that they are quite unlikely to
cause enhancement
if given at any good dose
got it thank you um is there a
neutralizing activity
outside of the rbd and how does this
correlate with
the prophylaxis in hamster challenge
there are neutralizing antibodies
against the end terminal domain and i
expect there are other
neutralizing antibodies against other
sites that will be discovered
in the fullness of time the quickest
path to neutralization
seems to be that direct block of
receptor binding the receptor binding
domain
got it um and then the next one i have
do you have any ethical concerns for
vaccines that are being developed
because of how quickly
they are being developed a lot of the
speed
in the vaccine development is
eliminating
things that are like administrative
delays so one example might be
let's just assume we're going to have
some vaccines and those vaccines are
going to need
syringes and refrigerated trucks and
nurses to administer them
so let's assume they're going to exist
and let's start figuring out our
logistics about glass vials and
refrigerated trucks and nurses
other things are just eliminating
administrative delays so typically you
might submit your packet of data
the review group would be convened
they meet the following month they'd
review the data it takes a week to write
the report that goes back to you you
have to jump all the hurdles for a clear
due to the next step
well right now you're writing up your
data it goes to the committee right away
they review it you know there might
there might be meeting
every single week or meeting more
rapidly by
zoom and they get you the information
back
that night or they might say okay look
we like data
a b and c we still need to see
experiment d
so set up experiment d and
l go ahead and get order what you need
to to do step
e while we're waiting for the results of
d to come back in so you don't have
delays and if we like it you can go
right into e
and not experience another month or two
delay and if we don't like it
we'll then pull the plug on d so a lot
of that a lot of the speed is just
reducing the normal number of
delays everyone's working 7 days a week
and 12 hours a day
to make this happen and another way of
reducing delays might be
let's say you were looking for
infection events in your phase 3 trial
so you have to vaccinate a lot of people
and then wait and see who
happens to get infected well if it's a
rare event
you might wait a long time to see it on
a small number of people but if you can
enroll
more people you might be more likely to
see those infection events and determine
if they're protected
so it's those kinds of things
administrative barriers and delays and
being strategic
that's giving us a lot of the
acceleration here
and i think it would actually be
unethical
to not try to
bring protection about to the world
i you know there's there's a lot of
effort to make sure that everything has
been thoroughly
vetted by safety no one's compromising
on
safety in these things what they are
compromising on
is sleep and weekends
thank you um when we actually have a
vaccine how will it be assured that all
individuals have
access to it for example those who are
uninsured
and how long will it take for it to be
available
i don't know the answers to those
questions um my expertise is more than
the molecular workings of how do you get
the
the right immune response so i don't
know i know there's been an effort by
different health departments to try to
figure that out and get that organized
ahead of time and figure out
how do you organize a priority maybe the
people that are the most vulnerable
our top priority maybe the people on the
front lines the medical workers are top
priority and how do you go
and build your distribution networks i
don't know the answers to all those
got it and then we have time for one
more question when do you predict a
reliable vaccine to be available for
covet 19
you know nobody
we don't i don't know uh and i think
every immunologist being asked this
question and
and most of us just aren't answering
because
we it's not available until we see all
the data and the data comes when the
data comes
and um
i don't know it's a wild guess spring
probably
early spring got it thank you so much dr
holman sapphire for your time today and
your important research
before we go i would like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
six
months until the march of 2021
labrus will alert you via email when
this is available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's
live event thank you again dr ullman
sapphire until next time goodbye
thank you